Ben Higgins and Lauren Bushnell are  livin it up in Sin City for their  bachelor and bachelorette parties  laurence powell and fellow bachelor  contestant ashley Iaconelli shared the  group's trip to vegas on social media  thursday documenting all their fun  festivities on snapchat happy  Bachelorette what's your name this  weekend Lauren channels her alter ego in  a jet-black wig and we even got a  glimpse of her hot whip and nae nae  moves as for the guys they were getting  hyped for the night by the pool Ben and  Lauren's bachelor bachelorette party  comes as a bit of a surprise just last  month the couple told ichi their wedding  planning was still a work in progress is  there a date we haven't set a date we  are really trying to figure out what's  best for us because our life has has  been going 100 miles an hour hopefully  next year and i'm yeah hoping that and i  think we're both on the same page when  it comes to that but no date yet